This week in prediction markets, we're seeing some fascinating shifts across technology,
legislation, and space exploration.
Our top story involves potential US legislation on deep fake content.
The probability of banning deep fake news has steadily climbed from just 0.7% to 5.9%
over the past week, signaling growing legislative momentum around digital consent and personal
protection.
In corporate drama, Adam Newman's WeWork buyback chances have dramatically fluctuated,
dropping from 11.6% to a current, 4.8%.
A bankruptcy judge's rejection of his purchase bid has essentially eliminated his prospects
of reclaiming the company he once led.
Our final highlight is SpaceX's Starship Launch Predictions.
While the market remains volatile, hovering between 1.4% and 3.5% this week,
recent successful test flights suggest increasing confidence in multiple space missions.
These markets demonstrate how quickly public sentiment and technological landscapes can shift,
reflecting the dynamic nature of our rapidly changing world.